so everyone and welcome to another very
nice game from round two of the 2019 3d
World Cup even though it just ended a
lot of you have requested it and for
good reasons it's a number one German
Grandmaster leave UD attorney CPA on
versus Hikaru Nakamura and well let's
just dive straight into it and and see
what happens
nisi bonum opens with Knight to f3 the
reti opening with Knight to f6 d 4 and E
6 with c4 d5 and now with Knight to c3
we of course transpose into the Queens
gambit declined Bishop to e7
and now g3 preparing to fianchetto the
light square bishop nakamura castles and
the bush up to G to D cap resin c4 now
with Knight to e5 and Queen to d6 it's
important to mention that Nakamura is
blitzing out all the moves that an easy
panel throws at him with castles by nice
panel and the camera goes Queen to a6
now defending the c4 pawn for the moment
with a 4 - panel and now it's
interesting that a nice panel already
had this position last year against Gil
Meyer with the black pieces and he
played rook to d8 here and this panel
was dead game but here Nakamura goes in
Knight to c6 so it's a different line
now comes Knight to b5 going after night
to c7 to fork the Queen and the rook
Knight captures on e5 first d captures
on e5 ended this is where the fun
happens the this position has been
reached before nothing new here you
don't want to move the knight as it
pretty much just traps your rook on f8
and it's hard to say when your knife
will get out
rook to d8 just going after the Queen
and there have been a few games where
Queen to c2 was played the bishop the d2
is a known move but the movie cpanel
played here is a new move in the
position and it's always interesting
that it's basically won one of the
angels top recommendations but it's uh
it has never been played nice piano
plays he captures on f6
a nice Queen sacrifice which gives white
a lot of compensation for his sacrifice
Queen and also a bonus question for
those of you
really follow chest and the for those of
you who have been subscribed to the
channel for quite some time now which
other famous game involves the Queen
sacrifice featuring the movie captures
on f6
or or maybe you know of maybe maybe even
two games that feature of Queen
sacrifice would it capture us on f6 that
is a bonus question for you we've
covered either either one of them or
both of them on this channel but okay
Nakamura of course accepts the Queen
there's nothing other to do here we have
rook after sandy one rope capture sandy
one and now you can't capture the pawn
for example if Bishop captures then your
C 7 point is hanging just Knight
captures your queen and rook our trap
you don't want to start giving more
material so after rook after sandy one
with Bishop to d6 guarding the c7 pawn
and now comes Bishop to f4 a very nice
move by an easy panel and now it really
what do you play here the problem is you
can't capture because Nakamura has the
background weaknesses the Ruby g8 is
checkmate so what can you do here you
could go Queen a5 it's a really
important move that guards the c7 pawn
even why once the for example the bishop
is captured you don't wanna allow Knight
captures here and also a possible move
here after Bishop to f4 is c3 also one
of the one of the suggestions and after
pawn captures let's say then you go
Queen to a5 but Queen to a5 a very
important defensive moves and move in a
lot of lines but here now Kimura also
blitzed out a 5 so all of the moves up
until this point point where blade style
by Nakamura and it's very interesting
because e 5 is the move that loses the
game believe it or not
so here what do you play but sub
captures on e5 is possible it's a free
pawn as the butcher you still cannot
capture due to due to the back ranked
weakness involving mate but nice banner
doesn't go for this nice banner goes for
Knight captures on d6 first and here
Nakamura has the capture on f4 that's
why it was better to just grab the e5
pawn because after this you give
Nakamura a chance to somehow well repair
his position if he plays he captures on
f4
then you continue the game 98 you go
after the g7 pawn also threatening
Knight to c7 again and after Queen to a5
finally getting the Queen there to
defend the pawn now you go rook to d8
and now you have to make some room for
King otherwise you know I discovered
check will be made and now this rook
comes the d1 and blacks position is just
disgusting
so after this Knight captures on d6 with
C captures on d6 the move that doesn't
work as now
Nissa panel goes to Bishop captures on
e5 and now again you have problems here
you can't capture again due to this mate
the problem is if you play G captures on
f6 you get rook captures on d6 attacking
the Queen on a 6 and after b6 defending
or moving the Queen just Bishop captures
here and now again you're threatening
mate there's the bishop covers the g7
square but also the rook is being
threatened as the bishop captures on a8
is a threat now so white and black is
completely busted here so after Bishop
captures only 5 with Queen to a5 finally
the Queen finds itself on this useful
defensive Square and now rook captures
on these six again the queen is now not
only guarding c7 but also d8 which is
very important to prevent mate of course
you cannot capture the bishop otherwise
you're still getting made it so here
Bishop to g4 Nakamura's develops the
piece and now the rook is finally
guarding the the last rank bishop the c3
now you don't want to allow Queen
captures on d5 now attacking Nakamura's
Queen Queen to c7 and now rook a to d1
again putting pressure under the 8
square for the moment it is defended but
you know a lot of things can happen g6
by nakamura now not allowing as the
bishop also now guards the g7 square is
not gonna allow F captors on g7 but now
Miss abano goes after him once again
Bishop captures on b7 just complete
annihilation here
you cannot capture if you capture then
again you allow
rook to d8 with rook captures and e8
mate and after Bishop captures on b7 you
get rooked f8 and a Kimura now has to
get the rook to a safe square bishop
to f3 Nakamura trades captures captures
and now h5 finally creating a space for
his King and now King to g2 we have rook
to e8 just now the door can be activated
and h4 just constricting black even
further with Queen to c8 by Nakamura and
now a5 just improving the position even
more there's not much you can do you're
never getting rid of this bishop here
you don't have a beep on aura or a deep
pond for that matter even if you did it
wouldn't really help you all that much
you're never getting rid of the f6 pawn
you're never getting rid of the double
rocks and the D file so if the queen or
rook moves just Ruby d8 will be very
strong and the black can just hopelessly
wait and see what white will do white we
have a six now the a6 pawn is defended
by the Queen rook d7 grabbing even more
squares from Nakamura with Queen to a8
not allowing rook to a7 to go after the
pawn or roof to d6 can also go after the
pawn so Queen to a eight just defending
here and now comes Luke one to d6
grabbing even more space again you can't
move the Queen order look from the back
rank rule D 8 will be deadly Nakamura
played rook the c8 and here even though
you can try a lot of ideas you can go
Ruby 6 followed by a rope here to maybe
go after the f7 pawn and then after rook
defends you can go rook a7 to grab be a
six pawn but Nyssa panel goes after the
a 6 pawn with Bishop to b4 now the
threat is rook to e7 and Nakamura
doesn't have a move here it's it's kind
of a Duke swank whatever you play just
completely loses for example yeah if you
move the Queen you lose the a6 pawn you
don't really have a good square for the
rook
for example rugby 8 from rook to e7
travels the Queen the Queen has no
squares so Nakamura tried c3 but now
just be captures on c3 and after rook to
e8
nice pan you just played Bishop to b6
and it was in this position I move 30
that Hikaru Nakamura resigned at the
game which is just amazing
number one a German player levy D
attorney C panel completely annihilates
Nakamura in in round two but okay they
still have to play one more game
Nakamura will get his chance with the
white pieces to get back into the
affiliate World Cup but it's not going
to be easy as now he needs a win and
it's never it's never easy when you
absolutely need a win here again you do
have a queen but you don't have a good
move you can just move the rook back and
forth but let's say rook c8 you can even
go rook b8 check and now for example if
this trade happens you are now just a
bishop completely winning but you don't
even have to try a ruby d8 because okay
the king can go to h7 but you can just
start for example pushing the c4 point
just c4 you're gonna go c5 c6 c7 black
and never capture if you captured Andrew
d8 check that's that's just being over
yeah a wonderful game by German number
one player after Bishop to b6 Nakamura
resigns the game and we're we're gonna
see what happens when the Komodo gets
the white pieces can't he get back into
the game
and perhaps not bliss out so many moves
in a row but we'll see what happens so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank all of our
outbreak and Marcel Fernandez for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos you're thinking for watching and
I will see soon continuing the coverage
of the fede World Cup checking up on
your wonderful suggestions as usual and
so on so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend